ولا طالما اصرت الولايات المتحده على ان
شبه جزيره القرم لا تزال جزءا لا يتجزا من
اوكرانيا ورغم الموقف الامريكي الصريح
بشان تبعيه القرن لكيهيف لكن تزويدها
بسلاح كاف قد يمكن اوكرانيا من استعاده
شبه جزيره القرم كما يتوقع البعض وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن كان شدد
في مطلع العام على ان بلاده لا تشجع
اوكرانيا على بسط نفوذها على الارض التي
خسرتها بالطبع لصالح روسيا في 2014 الا
انه وفي تصريحات اخيره للبيت الابيض تشير
الى تغير كلي في الموقف الامريكي للمره
الاولى حيث اكد مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي
انا واشنطن لا تمانع شن اوكرانيا لهجمات
على شبه جزيره القرد باسلحه امريكيه سولفا
قال في مقابله مع شبكه سي ان ان الاخباريه
الامريكيه ان بلاده لا تضعوا اي قيود في
وجه اوكرانيا لاستهداف الاراضي الواقعه
داخل حدودها والمعترف بها دوليا معتبرا ان
شبه جزيره القرم ارضا اوكرانيه محتله وقفه
وقفه توصيفي تصريحاته صلبا جاءت عاقبه
تزويد بطائرات اف 16 لاول مره فيما لا
تزال واشنطن لا تدعم شن هجمات اوكرانيه
باستخدام اسلحه الناتو في العمق الروسي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات